Please welcome, the hilarious Robin Thede!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
I've been waiting to meet you.
(applause)
I'm so happy to finally meet you!
Finally, I mean, since early one we've been.
Thank you.
Thank so much for coming.
I wore this for you.
You know, just a little sparkly thing.
I mean, it is everything.
Do you like it?
Okay, it's like a little Elvis, a little Vegas.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
And when do we not need a little Elvis?
Right?
We all need some joy, you know?
I've been old Elvis, I've been young Elvis.
You know, all the Elvises.
How are you?
I am so good and I'm so glad
that we're finally here together.
Me too.
We are such uber fans of yours over here,
and also the beautiful, incredible show that you created.
Yay!
I mean, and it gets taken seriously,
which I really appreciate, especially for comedy.
Yeah.
Which is usually, you know-
Kind of written off.
Yeah, no, we have been so lucky.
Our editors won an Emmy last year.
(Drew screams)
So exciting!
(applause)
And it's just so cool because,
it's all women of color who are editing the show,
it's history in the making,
so everything we do is not only fun and full of joy,
but it's also opening the door for so many people,
you know, who wanna do this too, so it's exciting.
It's so good too, the show.
Thank you.
I was binging it and it was giving me life because,
I always say it, comedy is my medicine.
Yeah, for sure.
Especially in these past few years.
We didn't know in 2019 when we were making the show
that we were going to, we were doing a fake storyline
about the end of the world,
about the four women on the show
living at the end of the world,
and then like 10 months later, it was the end of the world,
and we were like, it was four women trapped in a house
who could not leave.
Oh my God!
And literally, we've been exploring that storyline
for three seasons, so this season you will get answers
to how it was the end of the world and why.
So that is new information, just for you.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Now, I'm looking at this outfit.
Oh, this old thing?
Wait, there was a moment where I think you talked about
how Drake might be possibly tapping your style.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, well, that's my character, Chris,
for sure.
My character, Chris is a guy that has a beard and cornrows.
Yeah, there he is.
(crowd laughs)
I mean, you see it, look at the way
we're holding our phones!
It's like, literally, he is copying me.
This was two years ago, that was like a month ago, so,
you guys see it, right?
I mean, you guys see it, he's copying me.
I'm also, am I not a good looking man?
That's pretty amazing.
I was just about to go there.
I'm not kidding, I was like, "You are hot as a dude."
Thank you so much.
I get a lot more love as a dude than I do as a woman,
it's weird.
Don't feel bad for me, it's all fine.
I'll take all of it.
(crowd chuckles)
Okay, so, may I ask who you are named after?
Robin Williams.
Yeah, I know.
(applause)
I know.
So my dad was, is, is a massive fan of comedy
and he was just a massive Robin Williams fan,
as everyone with any intelligence is.
And it's so beautiful that that is your entry point
into the world and that your parents, again,
a little crystal ball happening in your family.
Well listen, I am nothing like the great Robin Williams,
and our comedy is very different,
but I think that it was permission for me to explore that.
And it was permission for me to not have those boundaries,
and when we would watch TV, I would mimic the news.
They'd be like, "Tonight at five" And I'd be like,
"Tonight at five" As a little kid, you know?
And they would be like, they would laugh
and they would go, "What is that?
Do that again." And they would just encourage it, you know?
And their only rule was you have to finish college.
So I finished college and then went to Second City
and that was the rest, but you know, they're teachers.
Well, my mom is in politics now,
she's in the house of representatives in Iowa.
Oh my God!
Which is amazing.
I know.
(applause)
I know, I know, I know.
First black woman in her district.
She's going into her eighth term, she's amazing.
Oh my God, that's so wonderful!
She's incredible.
So she is, you know, I'm making a sketch show.
She's like, "I pass marriage equality."
I'm like, "Great, good for you."
Okay, so you have a feature film in the works.
Yes.
What is going on there?
Okay, it's at Amazon, it's called, "Killing it."
It's a zombie comedy that's Sean of the dead
meets Girls Trip
Like a zomedy.
Yes, like a zomedy.
Like Sean of the dead, like Zombieland,
like any of those great movies.
So it's four black women who got expelled from Spelman
when they were in their senior year,
and they go back after 10, 15 years
to go to their homecoming to avenge
their tarnished reputations.
But they're kind of losers, and on the way to homecoming,
Atlanta gets taken over by zombies
and they have to save themselves and save the world.
But they're not good at it,
so I'm really excited about it.
You never get to see black women doing zombie, horror,
like comedy, you know?
So I'm really excited.
Yeah.
(applause)
(upbeat music)